I do want to run down your castmates
from this okay and do a little shade
away okay I named it a name and just
give me your quickest read on them down
for that oh I'm always down for that the
library is about to be open
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll start with Monique art loud
sometimes over the top crusty makeup
Trinity the Tuck plastic I can't really
read her that much I love her okay
but I just wish that she I just wished
that she yeah Naomi smalls well we're
still waiting for her to find a shoe
that fit Monet exchange well I got a lot
to say for her but I would just say
crusty makeup as well horrible fashion
still waiting for a good look from her I
haven't seen her look nice not one time
and yeah just kind of like Bob the drag
queen shadow so not sure that we even
all seek her okay a much [ __ ] too
sensitive for drag and just a head in
the clouds a little bit for me okay and
you called her a mr. grant model earlier
so well that's not an end result but
Instagram motto third meant for the
ground yeah literally like watch out and
bout the Jasmine masters
ghetto inappropriate sometimes and
look-wise i think underwhelming okay
Valentina late which also means
inconsiderate of other people the times
which would then lead to unprofessional
if you ask me being on time in any
industry I think is key early today
I sure was professional I also think her
fashion sense could be a little bit more
amped up your drag queen you are under
grace you know we need to feel a little
bit more for me but I get what she does
I just don't know that it's done the way
that she means it to be done yeah and I
just want her to realize that she's here
on earth
we're all human
you know you're you're not love heed him
to Guadalupe quite yet and you're not
Selena cuz you're not dead so just wait
remember you know and glamor
high-fashion a Latin American diva
Manu wanted the reads good and I'm
getting them so I'm the wrong person to
ask for those I don't know you're the
exact right person Manila manila
horrible finger I think she's a vocal
expresser just like me but definitely
not a finger I think she's sometimes all
over the place too with her aura okay
sometimes she's shady but then sometimes
she loves you but I'll be honest out of
all the drag race gross she was the only
one that came and saw me after my
surgery so that speaks volumes to me
speaks volumes Latrice I think her looks
have also been very underwhelming
borderline just cheap so I never like to
judge people but if I had to say I just
think her looks for me have been rough I
asked you for reads and you gave me read
so well honey we're only here to tell
the truth right you only live one life
and we can't live a life full of life
there we go so here we are
[Music]